all right so we began in Saudi Arabia
where Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
has detained some of the most
high-profile members of the royal family
and that includes former Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Nayef as well as a prince
of mint had bin Abdulaziz al-saud the
younger brother of the Saudi King report
suggests that they have both been
accused of treason Society guards have
also arrested one of Mohammed bin Nayef
brothers they are now likely to be under
the threat of life imprisonment or
possible execution both could have
rivaled Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
to the throne
if King Salman dies al Jazeera is senior
correspondent Jamal al explains what
these detentions mean for the kingdom
and their impact on Saudi politics in
terms of its significance it's huge
because we're talking about two of the
most senior members of the Saudi royal
family and two that up until now have
not been seen as supporters of
comprehends Mohammed bin Salman in the
direction that he's been taking the
country both domestically and in terms
of foreign policy what's prompted it is
very difficult to ascertain needless to
say because Saudis are very closed
culture in terms of lack of transparency
and no media freedom there but also
what's peculiar about it is that these
are two figures who have they've been
under house arrest they haven't been
able to move freely for very long time
so the idea that maybe they were trying
to hatch some sort of coup is very
far-fetched and difficult to see
considering the restraints they were
under already more likely than not what
a lot of analysts are talking about is
that the current king Salman is somebody
who has been reportedly suffering from
dementia for many years he's unwell his
health is very frail so is this a sign
that he has either passed or is about to
and therefore the crown prince needs to
ensure that there are no obstacles in
his way in terms of succession so now
I've been salman was able to get the
u.s. to ditch its long term ally in hama
B'nai if the person he's arrested and
supports him and he's got unconditional
support from this current US
administration he's managed to sideline
the religious institution either by
co-opting them onto his side or by
arresting many of them including people
like salman and older and others but the
royal
kourt's the royal family he has failed
to exert his total control over even
after he managed to do things like
rounding a lot of senior members of the
royal family in the ritz-carlton that
famous case in the end of 2007 there
were still those figures like the only
other child of the founding king king
abdulaziz that is ahmed being somebody
who didn't support him as well as his
cousin and the nephew of the current
King Mohammed Ben knife well let's hear
now from Holly just Shaun who's the
executive director of the Arab center of
Washington he thinks a detention seemed
like an attempt by the crown prince to
consolidate more power Prince Ahmed who
is the most senior of the three and has
lived actually overseas for many years
came back a couple of years ago to kind
of try to calm things down after MBS
took over and there were some kind of
turmoil within the royal family and of
course the the previous Crown Prince and
his brother were also involved in these
three arrests the accusation of course
or the implication is that there was an
attempt at a coup I I don't think the
possibility of a coup is even feasible
at this time in terms of where the
military is and its potential
participation and that I think this is
another attempt by Mohammed bin Salman
to kind of exert in a paranoid way his
full control over the kingdom definitely
there are some kinds of rumors and
innuendos that there is turmoil within
the family in the form of criticism but
that doesn't justify first of all the
accusation itself that they constitute a
threat in the form of a coup and to
justify this type of step you know being
arrested like criminals with masked
security forces coming to their homes
and yanking him out of their private
residences so this is this is not the
Saudi Arabia we all knew for five six or
10 or 20 years ago